president drop revealed plans for the
National Independence Day parade and
it's gonna be fierce you got music you
got flyovers fireworks buffets and tanks
he had lots of tanks plus his speech by
Trump himself me I don't like any
parades at my height it's all just the
backs of people's necks but damn you
could set your watch to the media
response what is the message Donald
Trump is trying to send by rolling tanks
down Constitution Avenue who is that
message to it's certainly not to tyrants
because he likes tyrants he loves
tyrants it's not to Putin it's not to
kim jeong-hoon it's not to the Saudis is
it to our friends is it to Western
democracy so he doesn't particularly
like or is it to us is it to the
resistance in this country I got tanks I
have this military Armada the message is
a threat and I hate to say that but I
think that Donald Trump's styles himself
a tyrant not a defeater of tyrants and
this is nauseating Kris because this is
not just obnoxious tackiness this is
actually dangerous
because it's fundamentally unamerican
clearly Donald Trump wants to transmit a
message of his strength because he
perceives himself as being seen as weak
around the world which he is suppose
what something that the president saw it
was about bolstering himself up looking
like a dictator from another nation for
a time that's for God so as predicted
the self-satisfied outrage that smirking
scorned you find whenever patriotism
rears its old-fashioned head just the
name salute to America is enough to make
journalism school grads puke
yes patriotism is easy to smear because
to the media feel so old like remnants
of a bygone era being ribbon candy penny
farthings or Joe Biden
how can you salute something so
inherently rotten they wonder the
mockery is exactly the opposite response
the media offers those who malign the
nation's symbols in fact it's a safe bet
that the same people heaping loads of
ridicule on a July 4th parade are also
heaping loads of praise on Colin
Kaepernick Nike and athletes who scorned
the national anthem it's the same
mockery reserved for Trump who as you
know it's just a hood ornament on that
jalopy we call America it's the same
score directed at you and me or anyone
not edge
enough to see the horrors of loving your
country I'm sure some hope that the
parades a flop a disaster and
embarrassment not me and certainly not
you you may not even need a parade or
want one but you're getting one anyway
because some old guy who loves this
country like you do became president and
this happened to be on his list it would
probably have been on yours too
all right want in the greenroom you were
telling me how much you hate America you
hate America so much that you hate this
parade well you really didn't say that
but I thought you said I gotta say I
happen to agree with much of what you
played in that montage because to me
we're not surprised 1 I love parades and
I love the 4th of July and I love
America but I must say I don't think
that what Trump is doing is about
America I think it's about President
Trump and he's politicized this event
and it's now now they've got you know
that baby Trump balloon is going to be
on the mall they've got Trump sitting on
the pot on the mall I'm like how why
would anyone turn the 4th of July into a
polarizing event in the midst of
tremendous political polarization that
exists in our country he's not
polarizing anything you guys still you
guys politicized it you're the ones
polarizing it if you have a celebration
of our American military and you have
some f-22s and some Abrams tanks and
some flyovers if you guys on the left
are offended by that and that you think
the President of the United States the
commander in chief is gonna roll the
tanks over the resistance because he
thinks it's Tiananmen Square
you're the ones politicizing the event
he's just trying to show off all the
hardware we bought so he's trying to
celebrate America let me ask you
something why then is he in the White
House handing out tickets to a select
section for his biggest supporters why
is that Jesse why wouldn't he oh because
it's a political event if it's a knock
when the president United States is
there if a Democrat did this which
they've done JFK did you've done it
throughout history I'm sure you hear
that had some tickets to his buddies
yeah by the way I mean dagen if if this
if the big problem here is handing out
tickets
the country's going pretty pretty good
if that's the big the big story today
you know good it's going it's free and
say the fireworks which were donated
it's about three-quarters of a million
dollars from two fireworks companies
including Gucci Gucci and phantom
three-quarters of a million dollars free
15-minute fireworks showed 19 thousand
firework devices they even have this
exclusive pixel bursting American flag
it's gonna be seven hundred feet wide
600 feet tall you can see that unfurl
and not even have to lay eyes on
president Trump can I just say I find it
hilarious watching these montages of the
huffin and puffin media because they
don't realize that President Trump has
taken up residence in their heads that
he is their son their world revolves
around him they can't get out of bed in
the morning unless he's up tweet already
because he gives them life he has turned
them into ranting and raving lunatics
who hate fireworks and the forces which
is crazy yeah well and look it's about
the military right and yet these are the
same people who say you talk about how
important the military is and how they
love our troops and veterans and yet the
complaints are that there's going to be
tanks there's going to be the tools of
the trade that we never see that keep
this nation safe that allow us to enjoy
life every single day not just on the
fourth of July but it's the nature of
it's not just you sign up for the
military
you go and you train to fire that weapon
you train to run the tank you treat you
you're a pilot yeah I mean it's not that
we're hoping and wishing that we keep
the nation safe people in uniform do
that using those tools it is a
celebration of them and I think this is
what America sees in the complaints it's
like why are you why do you have a
problem with with the military
celebration of the military
in fact the Chiefs of the military won't
be there for just that reason
and you know what now that's not for
just that the Chiefs of the military
remember this is a president who got out
of military service with bone spurs oh
you got to go to that
it's the port your argument at the very
least he's at least making up for things
that people complain about in the past
if whatever he's been doing and whatever
he's done up until now he has changed
the trajectory of this country in all of
our lives and so that's good enough I
have a theory that the media hates this
because it's not for them it's for the
country they like it this is actually
the fourth of July parade is actually
the reverse of the Correspondents Dinner
the press goes quick for two weeks three
weeks you hear about the Correspondents
Dinner they can't wait they can't wait
they can't wait nobody else cares this
is the reverse of that it's it's like
the x-ray version right yes the absolute
difference and it is embarrassing for
them but in the in the in the long run
the American people hear that and this
is a worry for liberals because I think
most liberals also love the military in
love the country and it makes no sense
what the media has been saying about it
what's not to love about the country
we're fabulous women I'm just confused
this is what this is about Donald Trump
no wearing glasses okay turning the 4th
of July into a Trump campaign rally and
you're saying it's about the military no
it's about the nation and it's about the
4th of July he happens to be the
president how great for us is that when
you look at your fir away I think it was
George Kelly Kelly Ann's husband in
security speaks loudly like this I mean
and by the way to your point thinking
about money why is the National Park
Service having to give up two or three
million dollars they won two or three
million dollars and you proposed a
hundred trillion dollars 30 million
dollars the National Park Service spent
for their hundred million dollar for
their 100-year anniversary 30 million
dollars for themselves I just say one
question I think I see a little tuft of
kind of orange
blonde hair above your ear because he's
so far in your head do you think so no
all right okay let's move on